it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we expose the big cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to fox news contributor raymond arroyo
now raymond
protests are a part of american life but
some are
more appropriate than others well i'll
let you judge where this one falls laura
but over the weekend at joel osteen's
lakewood church in houston abortion
activists bracing for that supreme court
decision that could overturn roe v wade
decided to protest during pastor
osteen's service watch
it's my body my
choice
i do what i think and do because i have
a choice i have a choice
um this is my protest it is misplaced
and now she has been misplaced why are
they disrupting joel osteen's service
laura i mean i guess it's because it's
televised live but he's hardly a
pro-life fire brand and if you're going
to protest in a church what does taking
your clothes off achieve aside from i
guess reminding people near you that
it's time to update their peloton
subscriptions
i don't know what that does ray if
you're going gonna take your shirt off
in public get the abs a little tighter
first okay just a little bit sorry i
mean seriously
this i mean we're gonna see many more of
this type of protest i hope these people
don't continue to do it during religious
services that's off limits and and
probably the year's most notorious
protest laura was will smith smacking
chris rock in the face over his joke at
the oscars now the target of that joke
jada pinkett smith is finally speaking
out on her red table talk show about
alopecia and that infamous moment
now about oscar night my deepest hope
is that these two intelligent capable
men have an opportunity to heal talk
this out
and reconcile the state of the world
today
we need them both and we all actually
need one another more than ever
wait a minute wait a minute it was jada
pinkett smith who was infuriated that
her husband and the crowd laughed at
chris rock's joke it was she who had a
word with will smith before he stormed
the stage i mean this is like lady
macbeth weeping over duncan's death or
meghan markle complaining that she was
cut out of the jubilee events this is
your fault you caused this i i hate this
kind of justification after the fact
trying to wash yourself of of of guilt
here it's really a bad look it's the
whole thing is
i i'm so tired of it but yet we're drawn
to it like a really bad car crash
it's horrible horrible
it's the need to justify in public and
try to wash one's sins just confess it's
easier and laura the most important
protest perhaps of the century was
brilliantly executed 78 years ago today
i'm speaking of the d-day invasion the
allies not only attacked nazism and
liberated europe but showed the power of
a united free people fighting bravely
and for the common good you and i were
in normandy for that 75th anniversary of
d-day and it was incredible emotional
standing on that sacred ground and
looking at those nearly nine thousand
four hundred markers in the american
cemetery
and uh we spoke to some of those d-day
veterans you'll remember laura but only
a few dozen showed up this year given
their ages uh though
98-year-old
jake larson went back to normandy beach
for likely his final visit here's what
he told nbc about his brothers
i feel their presence right now their
souls are right here
witnessing this i'm not the hero
i'm here to tell you
the heroes are buried over here the
message is protect our freedom honor
these heroes that have given their life
at a young age
honor these people
god bless him and all those men who
sacrifice so much but laura what a
disgrace that it took the white house
and the president until 8 45 tonight to
issue a tweet about d-day now biden has
issued full-blown proclamations for
everything from pride month to earth day
but no d-day proclamation but they did
get a tweet to honor these heroic
warriors this is woefully inadequate god
bless them and we should recall their
sacrifice
every day
that why am i not surprised by that
raymond it's but we were there for the
75th that was
i think i was bawling most of the time
it was so moving and so beautiful so
well laura it's it's like the queen this
weekend this is someone with duty and
dignity they put service first that's
what these men embody and we could all
learn a lot more from that particularly
our young people it's a disgrace this
wasn't elevated and talked about no now
we tear things down raymond thank you
for that hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else